in 1922 Soviet filmmakers II Gewehr Tov
wrote about his hatred of DW Griffith
and other popular directors at the time
for making movies that he called carbon
copies of novels and theatres the camera
is a boring objective spectator watching
the action unfolds and there must be a
plot relayed to the viewer with title
cards he calls it leprous mortally
dangerous and contagious his response
was a man with a movie camera a
documentary that changed the way people
made movies forever the camera becomes
the character in the movie showing us
how he pulls off his different shots he
made strides in slow motion double
exposure and split screens he makes his
goal very clear in the title sequence no
sets no actors no scripts no title cards
only the absolute language of cinema on
the basis of its complete separation
from the language of theater and the
novel and it's in this way of thinking
that he used the then experimental Dutch
angle which shows up several times in
the movie along with the other camera
innovations and while he was not the
first to use the Dutch angle he knew
exactly how to do it
the Dutch angle exploded in the 90s and
early 2000s appearing just about
everywhere from action movies to soap
commercials the problem comes from using
the shot as a crutch to make a boring
shot interesting just tilt the camera
Battlefield Earth was over 90% Dutch
angles as Roger Ebert put it the
director Rodger Christian has learned
from better films that directors
sometimes tilt their cameras but he has
not learned why the tradition goes right
up to 4 in 2011 director Kenneth Branagh
says he was going for a comic-book look
but I think there's more to looking like
a comic book than adding Dutch angles to
half the movie I also can't help but
find it kind of cheesy when it's used to
make the villains crooked and that's
probably because of where that idea
first came from what the dynamic duo at
school what I'm trying to say is these
movies don't capture the spirit of the
shot the most important movie for Dutch
angles is arguably the cabinet of dr.
Caligari in 1920 the movie was years
ahead of American cinema at the time
it's incredible use of shadows and light
and Euler set pieces and twist ending
brought Expressionism from literature
and paintings to the big screen this
daring German style quickly found its
way into American cinema the extreme
lighting defined the film noir and the
horror elements found their way into all
kinds of blockbusters I had a quiet
strong Germany
by working of the Cooper Studios Burley
the influence goes right up to timber
and set pieces and character design he
never directly cites German influence
but there's no doubt his work screams
Expressionism and even he mixes in the
Dutch angle in his expressionistic
movies I like when he uses it to
exaggerate the mundane like losing your
bicycle but the most crucial aspect of
the cabinet of dr. Caligari is the
introduction of subjective filmmaking
this movie was the first twist ending in
film history when Francis is actually in
an insane asylum and his experiences are
delusions the movie presents its world
in a subjective way what we see is not
reality but actually the subjective
experience of the narrator so while the
movie doesn't have explicit camera tilts
the tilting of the set and the tilting
of the narrative introduces the idea
that movies can be hyper realistic and
more than filming traditional set-pieces
movies can be subjective so really the
Dutch angle arises out of two movements
the Soviet experimental documentary and
German Expressionism one movement
introduced the innovative camera
techniques focusing entirely on the
cinematic aspects and the other focus on
how the theatrical and artistic elements
could be subjective and unique maybe the
perfect use of the Dutch angle comes in
the third man an incredible noir about
the black market in post-world War two
Vienna the landscape of Vienna is the
German expressionist vision come to life
with its jarring angles and ruins
landscape you can't help but notice the
similarities in the crooked ruins of
Vienna and the bizarre set pieces of the
cabinet of dr. Caligari in the third man
the camera itself acts as another tilt
in the already crooked world of
post-world War two Vienna and sometimes
the camera doesn't even need to tilt
because the street does it by itself
within the frame lines of all sorts of
angles add to the angle created from the
camera tilts the Dutch angle contributes
to the distortion already on screen
giving cinema a way of adding
uncertainty that no other art form can
do not in theatre and not in the novel
but the crooked angles do more than
enhanced the landscape during Holly's
questioning of each witness the crooked
angles make their confessions feel a bit
off and remind you never to be quite
sure who to believe
during Harry's monologues the ferris
wheel tilts while the camera holds
steady
creatively integrating Dutch angles into
the shot it fits nicely with Harry's
personality as his dialogue quickly
switches from playful jesting to
threatening
murder don't think they'd look for a
bullet wound after you hit that clown
the crooked vienna landscape ambiguous
characters extreme lighting and plot
twists echo the design of German
Expressionism and the experimentation of
the Soviet documentary it's a movie
begging to have Dutch angles many more
recent movies use the shot in similar
ways and diehard villain Hans Gruber
pretend he's just a civilian
during his back-and-forth with John
McClane every shot is at least a little
bit tilted this medium shot on Hans is
the most tilted in the scene his shadow
is long and exaggerated the camera is
off-center and the tension is perfect as
soon as John McClane gives him a gun the
scene feels just like the third man the
Dutch angle till adds to the uncertainty
of the moment we know something and
we're not sure John McClane has any idea
and for all we know he could get killed
any second maybe I prefer this reveal
over lamest because it's so obvious in
Leamas their villains the Dutch angle
feels forced the shot seems to fit
better in moments of tension and
uncertainty when things aren't as they
should be it's no coincidence that a
movie with many great Dutch angles is
called doubt I like the way they make
you feel it's been a bit of controversy
about them as people feel that they call
too much attention to themselves but
actually you know I just watch other
movies that are filled with touch angles
and you don't realize it because they
use them so much it doesn't particularly
mean anything even all these years later
the movies with well-thought-out Dutch
angles still have the Expressionism and
then out in back of these same apartment
buildings were these German
expressionistic alleys and they also
have the experimentation and it
producers came in and said look you know
you also gotta shoot it for square in
case this doesn't work which I certainly
couldn't blame them for doing but ended
up liking it very much they even put it
in the trailer the kind of Dutch angles
I enjoy seem to be the ones that stayed
true to where the shot came from the
angle shows off what makes filmmaking
unique through its emotional
manipulation of a scene so when your
moment features the classic unsettling
nature of the cabinet of dr. Caligari
then it's perfect and when you use it
just because it looks cool it seems to
lose some weight but I'm not trying to
say that there's some obvious way to use
the Dutch angle it's a very emotional
shot you may enjoy how it feels in
movies that I don't and we're both right
or you could say I'm looking too far
into the shot and the Dutch angle is
just a way to tilt the camera to make us
seem interesting but I think
you look more closely you can see how
the shot means quite a lot the shot in
many ways represents the original intent
of directors to use filmmaking as a
unique art form the tilting of the
camera is the purest form of subjective
filmmaking the unease of the Dutch angle
makes cinema special because you can't
do it in theatres or the novel and when
it's used it pushes boundaries for what
movies are capable of so what I'm saying
is the Dutch angle is a perfect
representation of what makes movies
better than all that other crap
you wanna go yep if you want to learn
more about cinematography and how to
make your own filming look like a high
budget movie
I recommend this course by
cinematographer Ryan booth he gets in
depth about how the professionals like
their scenes and shoot on location it's
actually rare to have someone so
experienced get into such detail online
the first 500 people to click on the
link in the description below can get
two months of completely free access to
Skillshare that's Ryan booths class and
over 20,000 other classes across
cinematography video editing photography
marketing business and tons of other
ones if you're not a filmmaker you can
still definitely find a valuable course
in there thousands of classes
I'm personally brushing up on my editing
skills in there Adobe After Effects for
beginners class thanks for watching
transform just a bit of a break from the
norm just a little something to break
the monotony of all that